taste buddies Tasties hi before we get
started with this episode of taste buds
I just want to tell you warn you maybe
the audio is a
little uh we had some technical issues
unfortunately and the audio is not up to
speed you know that usually on this show
it is topnotch picture topnotch audio
top-notch content if I do say so myself
uh but this week uh it's not top-notch
audio uh we had a we had a hiccup with
the uh I don't
know I don't do the tech talk people a
microphone or something got screwed up
something went bad anyway so we had to
use the backup audio for this episode
which doesn't sound as good and you will
notice but we do think that it's still
listenable and we did think that it was
a good episode and an episode we really
enjoyed doing so we didn't want to not
give it to you on this fine Christmas
day so Merry Christmas today Christmas
Day and if you're watching this not
today well
then you missed out you missed
Christmas uh have a happy holiday we
thank all of you for being a part of
this show for supporting it regardless
of your faith we really do appreciate
you that was my uh Santa alarm just went
off I gotta get downstairs and open some
gifts people all right listen we love
you guys uh and thank you for being part
of another great year another great
season of taste buds and we'll see you
in 2024 now enjoy folks this is Joe de
Roa and I am hitting that big Open Road
in the year 2024 with my new hour I
Never Promised You a Rose Garden where's
it kicking off well it's kicking off
right here in New York City at the grar
theater on January 13th January 19th and
20th I will be at the comedy Mothership
four shows uh doing my thing in Austin
Texas February 8th we got Nashville at
basement East February 9th Charlotte at
the underground February 15th San Fran
at the Swedish American Hall folks I
then go on February 16th to Hollywood
San Diego on the 17th then in March we
got Palmdale California Portland Oregon
uh Seattle Washington we're adding more
dates every day also reschedules for the
dates I just had to cancel are coming up
so keep your eye out anyway you want
tickets you want show info go to jod
rosa.com that's jod rosa.com for all
info and ticket links guys good news and
bad news bad news is you cannot see me
on the road any longer doing my material
because I finished my special and it
will be coming out in the spring of 24
thank you Chicago you are amazing here's
the good news when I'm not doing my solo
tour I'm doing the group tour so come
see me and the guys from impr practical
jokers tour kicks off in just a couple
of weeks in January we're in Highland
California we're in Vegas baby at
Resorts World Theater and then at the
mullet arena in Tempe Arizona then we
got the Impractical Joker cruise with
Eric Andre and a ton of other people
Felipe Esparza steveo Adam Ray um just a
ton of great stuff happened on that one
and there still are some cabins left
it's our fifth one it's going to be
insane get shipfaced ccom or shipfaced
cruise.com come along that's January
22nd to the 26 from there we go to
Florida we're doing the Hard Rock in
Hollywood we're doing the uh seminal
Casino in Tampa and uh then the Hard
Rock Casino in Cincinnati uh then in
April Youngstown Ohio at the golli
center a couple at the Chicago theater
right there a couple at Foxwoods uh and
then in June Atlanta at the Symphony
Hall mobile Mobile Alabama at the Sanger
theater so we are going to be all over
uh check out impracticaljokers.com or
really just go to savc comedy.com to get
tickets I hope to see you guys on the
road this is the last second leg and
last leg of the Joker's tour as well
well so when we're done with this
one taste buddies time to t a s t e buds
said time to not welcome to time te it
is time don't beat yourself up over it I
won't I won't uh we are here
today we are gathered here today yes to
to to battle I can't believe I cannot
believe that we have never we just did a
search of our history of our episodes
and neither of these have ever appeared
I have tried that's wild many times in
the past to get potato salad into a
battle but we just never I don't know
for whatever reason we never been called
yeah uh baked potato I'm shocked how has
that not been in a battle I'm shocked
it's never even come
up uh you know what let's do something
we've never done done I want to already
read some of the phone
comments right off the pet you want to
just start you want to just use them as
want to you want to want to read them
and then just use those to comment off
of uh yeah sure potato salad is what
Foley and Kippy Kevin Ryan grw up eating
cuz it's straight trash all right uh
only vinegar based potato salad though
not Mayo based I agree with but it's
okay it's still potato salad includes
both I love a German but on the in
general don't I can't stand a Mayo Bas
this this this comment I love macaroni
salad but something about potato salad
grosses me out okay we're not asking
about macaronis no we're not also I feel
the reverse I feel the potato Sal is
disgusting baked potato is the worst
form of potato I love cold potatoes no
one all right potatoes are not meant to
be eating cold you got me it
baked I usually go for the one that's
less
healthy
uh baked baked potato all the way I love
that this this big mic goes sour cream
bacon bits shredded cheese DIC J baked
potato all the way oh Mike that's funny
that's all the ingredients of most
potato salads what you just W is it
really I a potato salad bacon definitely
chives sour cream is part of the mixture
this what you're going to pull here it's
true you're going to say basically you
let the baked potato get cold and you
have a baked potato salad no I'm saying
his version of a baked potato well that
is the key ingredients of a baked potato
right the only way a potato Stacks up if
is if it's a baked potato salad wait
what oh that's the only potato Sal
honestly dis the baked potato to put
against soggy soggy does anybody know
anything these comments are making me so
mad right now about potatoing it I'm
liking it this is
ridiculous serial killers like cold
potato it is the number one Deli side
salad it's true potato salad can you go
back a little bit just a few right there
baked potato burns my I I saw a negative
for baked potato baked potato burns my
mouth every single time well I think
that's more of a you problem there's no
way around it yes the kind of is potato
salad reminds me of Summer barbecues and
especially right now I need that feeling
that is a you know aside from you know
the fact that they don't realize that
they don't have to burn their mouth and
B potatoes for the rest of their lives
yeah that's a good take absolute
abomination won't even eat the potato
what is everybody talking about it's in
every Deli and Super Market Deli counter
across the goddamn country you you do
know and you do recognize that both
macaroni salad Co slaw and and potato
salad they're all polarizing because of
one guy who Mayo well but here's what I
don't understand yes there's there's can
other types of potato salads they're not
accounting for that for this many people
to be talking about look at this look at
this look at this lady I I you know oh
wait no she's on my
side all I saw were the words baked
potato at Walmart and I was like Jesus
God a baked potato loaded all right
there's a baked potato fully loaded
potato salad from Walmart well there you
go you just said that and I promise you
it's got all the ingredients that Big
Mike likes probably the toughest one you
guys have done all right this guy Burke
guy I may be poor but got poor enough to
think baked potatoes are
good wait baked that's a slight on baked
potatoes yeah that's funny though it is
true listen let let's do the battle chat
ready time to b a t t l e buzs I'll say
right now off of that a baked potato in
h the item you find on a on a on a
steakhouse on a fine dining menu is
about five classic sides and one of them
it's mashed potatoes and it's and it's
baked potatoes and they bring them over
they look like little little footballs
and it's piping hot they split it down
the middle and as a kid I didn't like
baked potatoes and I'll tell you what I
often don't even order baked potatoes
but when when I do I maybe have one
every I'll call it one every two years
maybe three I remember like wow I really
enjoy what I'm doing here I potato salad
is available for me in that time span
maybe another maybe 50 60 times I will I
will tell you something and I hate to
burst your bubble yeah I have been going
to a good amount of steak type places in
recent
months baked potato is not as prevalent
as it used to be it is not on a lot of
menu this is how you're telling me that
you just going to say that it's not dude
I you see you see potato wedges you see
like their their version of home fries
or whatever point being though but you
have to usually say can you do a baked
potato they do a mash dude I went to
Burger and lobster the other night my
buddy Brian that's a great spot if
you've never been and uh they had the
the lobster comes with french fries and
I go can I get a baked potato with that
because I was trying to just be sort of
healthy the gu's like n we don't we
don't do it I have also here's the other
pain in the ass with a baked potato I've
been to this is this is batshit but it's
true I have been to restaurants and said
can I have a baked potato and they go we
don't make them before this time like
like because they take so long they're
like we won't do it until like the sh is
here at 5:00 there a lot of TLC that
goes into baking a potato right you're
just tossing the macaroni Sal macaroni
salad is not on any menu but a diners
potato salad oh sorry potato salad it's
not on any menu but a diners not true
not not true delad Deli menu diner oh no
Diner Deli that's two places deli's
menu yeah if you go to like cats's or
something or not cats's but if you go to
a like Second Avenue Deli they have
potatoes out okay but I'm saying a sit
down Deli where you can eat okay you
know delices yeah like a Jewish or
Italian deli where you can sit down and
eat or whatever which was one of the
battles we did we were G that was a good
one man I saw that anyway um they have
potato salad diners will have potato
salad also potato salad is one of those
side dishes that sneaks into I don't
want to say fancy but some more
Niche maybe a little high-end type of
restaurants because they'll do a
variation of a potato salad well
anything could be elevated but but but
that's a needle and well you're not
going to see that with macaroni salad
and colato salad I of have fine dining
and I do not see potatoes uh I you
know I I I can't stand the May based
ones but I love a good German you know
what I mean German I I spit it in your
face really it's you like the May based
ones exclusively that's what they're
talking about when they recoil you know
yeah let's make something clear right
it's the same exact food right it's the
same food so I'm not saying one is
better than the other but why do you
find one on you know they charge more
for one one is why do why do I not like
the German no no no no I'm sorry the
baked potato and and potato Sal is
coming from the exact same core food I
like both it's the preparation that sets
it apart oh dude you excitement of the
preparation of a baked potato okay you
getting that thing piping it's still
solid like a brick you get it wrapped in
that foil they split it open okay he
still got the skin on it and then they
put cold sour cream in there with the
chives and the bacon and then you could
eat out of its own body like it's its
own bowl no that's wild because if you
leave a little room in there you're just
carving out the potato and at the end
you can pick it up and just snap right
into it first of all the the the what it
takes more it's well thought out what it
takes to put a potato salad together it
is such time and what does it take well
well hold on I was going to say you got
to it's such time and care and love
there's a reason why dude potato salad
is is is a is is like a tradition dish
like people will say you know when I go
what I'm coming to the picnic of course
I'm bringing my potato out like that it
is a dish that that people make to to
they're known for their potato salad I
mean a great potato salad it it can be
amazing but it takes a lot of time man
it takes a lot of effort here's where
the fault is going to come in for you
the the association for potato salad for
most of the population and probably the
most popular variation of potato salad
is just dunking that stuff in mayo
that's the deli one that's your standard
one that's the one that's like a150 a
pound you get the whole thing it's not
always gross sometimes it's good but
like yeah it's it's and that's why no
one's like oh like let me think about
this person's famous potato salad or you
know like but that's but here's the
thing dude you go into any
Supermarket that's not like you know
that's not like a very you know I most
supermarkets I'll put it that way you go
into most supermarkets you there are
these ver dude most supermarkets in the
deli counter case where they have the
salads and stuff they'll have like three
types of potato salad they'll have the
one you're talking about which is like
the whatever then they'll have the one
with egg and stuff and then they'll have
the one with like bacon and sour cream
and everything like most places where
you can buy potato they're going to have
a variation they're going to have
options um but I'm telling you something
dude you baked potato there is nothing
more let me read this just just just let
me read this this this kind of Craig
this is a bad comparison these two would
typically be served together at most
barbecues SLO versus potato cell or
beads
Craig we don't
care e
audacity oh God never trust anything in
a restaurant made with mayonnaise I I
don't understand is this a fascinating
angle isn't this a fascinating
realization uh or observation the baked
potato has less prep time right you just
take in a whole freaking potato maybe
you wash it it takes like an hour though
right right right but but prep time sure
right you you're washing a potato
quickly and you're wrapping into and
you're setting it down right that's all
you're doing there like there's nothing
to it it's the most basic thing you
could do you're heating up a whole
potato you're trying to elevate it by
splitting it open and putting all the
you know the dress you know the stuff in
there right and that's what elevates
that like if that wasn't in there and
that was on a restaurant like no we'll
just bring you one whole warm potato and
you eat it it would be like what do you
is that a joke you're just going to me a
whole heated up potato and that's the
meal right right no no so that's
everything right so it gets elevated
afterwards right the prep time for you
is harder you got to peel them wash them
peel them and then no you don't have to
peel them I I like a skin on potato
salad I'm not okay but you still have to
then you still have to dice them all
that's big big time yeah yeah no you
don't have to dice not dice whatever
whatever you want call yeah it's it's
it's usually the smaller potato and you
quarter it it's not it's not terrible
it's not terrible well I've seen them
I've seen them also like in discs
somebody in your life makes a potato
salad yeah that is so good and so
incredible that you called me my lady
yes and said you have to try this and
then I tried to figure out if there was
a way that she could make it in mass
quantities so I could sell it at the bar
that's how good second time she made it
you had it wasn't even good it was very
good still but I'm telling you something
you have you ever ever had a baked
potato that made you do that that made
you go I got to call about the baked
potato that's a good point because what
you gain in potato salad is the ability
of have many different recipes and for
the most part a baked potato is a baked
potato I but what the point I was trying
to make was there's more goes into to
the prep of it more elbow grease you got
to you know but then then where in as
the baked potato gets elevated from a
just a you know you're you're dicing the
potato and then you're dressing it down
no pun inten you're dressing it down
you're just tossing it into this Mayo
based kind of thing and just mixing it
around like the baked potato like the
potato let you dressing up a pig but in
this one you're slicing the pig apart
then you're throwing it and you're
tossing it in its own swne
no that's not true you know wouldn't you
agree no no you agree what percentage
would
you most listen here's where I feel
about the potato in
general all right most potato dishes
that are worth their salt is the potato
saying to you I'm here do what you will
with me let's go and you got to take
that potato in certain directions it
might be one of the most versatile Foods
it is but I mean you're you're turning
it into a tot you're you're French
frying it in some certain way you're
you're Bing a potato salad you're doing
a twice baked potato which is a whole
other ball game but oh thank you for
bringing that up but that's not doesn't
count in your argument yes it I twice
baked no
no you're telling me every ingredient
any one on the planet that you want to
you tell me you can get four this potato
this you're using 10 different potato
salads I
that's not a baked potato they going to
disagree hold on a second a baked potato
is a baked potato a twice baked is you
scoop out the baked potato turn it into
some sort of flavored mash and then
recook it you're in almost potato salad
ter territory at that oh wait that's not
where you like bake it twice just for
the of the heating reason no the reason
you bake it twice is because you scoop
it out and you like do stuff to it and
then rebake it as the new thing do stuff
to it it's it's a real chees oh okay
then maybe I was I was thinking like
what's what isn't there things that you
like bake twice or something like that
just because of the texture and like how
it will yield baking it twice T well
let's C let's just read a recipe for for
for twice baked potatoes the recipe will
tell
us let's just go to one of the recipes
basically what you do is you bake some
potatoes scrape out the insides then add
a bunch of yummy stuff and mix it
together then you fill the scraped out
potato shells with the new potato make
sure top of with cheese and bake it
again okay okay it literally sounds the
way I
described almost the exact but but
actually in reading that at the end of
the day that is a no it is not that is
making mashed potato prepping but you're
prepping your potatoes any way you want
the bottom line is I'm baking the potato
not once but twice it's even it's a
still a baked potato that is called a
twice baked potato it's in the family of
the baked potato you're you're baking
the potato you know godamn well what a
biged potato is but then why can you do
10 different potato
salads because potato salad is potato
salad folks uh I'd like to talk to you
about well erectile dysfunction there's
no other way to say it uh in all
seriousness 52% of men 52% of men who
are over 40 experience some form of Ed
erectile dysfunction between the ages of
40 and
70 uh and it's you know look it's a
little bit of a weird topic sometimes to
bring up some people think it's t taboo
or or or uncomfortable whatever but I
want to tell you that thanks to hims one
of the great sponsors here at Tas buds
things are changing hims is providing
affordable access to erectile
dysfunction treatment and guess what
it's all done
online all right that's it
why why is this important well because
things functioning the way they're
supposed to function allows you to have
confidence confidence throughout every
aspect of your life whether you're in
the office or sitting at the dinner
table or on the Dance Floor whatever it
is you're doing you know at the baseball
game at the Rock concert doesn't matter
all right you you
you you you want to feel confident you
want to feel confident and you want to
be able to know that you're going to be
able to get it on and popping when you
get back to that bedroom do you know
what I'm saying all right so with HS you
can get access to medications that
ensure your erectile dysfunction gets
treated so you can keep that confidence
going all day all night you want a
better sex life have better sex do you
want to do these things but erectile
dysfunction is getting in the way if so
hey I'm here to tell you you're not
alone okay there are millions of men
dealing with this Millions but HS is
here to help with a simpler affordable
way to treat the issue okay so get your
groove back in the bedroom at a cost
that you desire hims has hundreds of
thousands of trusted subscribers so if
ere erectile dysfunction is getting you
down it's time to change that there's no
insurance needed you pay one low price
for your treatments online visits uh
ongoing shipments and provider messaging
uh and by the way you you go on you
answer a series of questions on their
site and then a medical provider will
determine the right treatment option for
you if prescribed your medication ships
directly to you for free and Indiscreet
packaging this is the best way to do
this so anyway start your free online
visit today at hs.com tastbuds that's
hs.com tastebuds for your personalized
Ed treatment options hs.com
tastebuds prescriptions require an
online consultation with a healthc care
provider who will determine if
appropriate restrictions apply see
website for details and important safety
information subscription required price
varies based on product and subscription
plan folks do you like to go to those
big events the sporting event the
concert event the comedy event the
theater event but maybe you don't like
buying those tickets for the big events
way in advance or maybe you just want to
know when you're buying those tickets
you're getting the best deal possible
well people that's where game time comes
into the picture all right you go to the
game time app you browse through and you
can
see all the information about all the
upcoming events in your area okay and
they're going to offer you last minute
tickets they're going to offer you flash
deals they're going to offer you Zone
deals it's easy to find and buy the
tickets for every kind of event in your
area you can see what it looks like from
where you're going to be sitting with
seat views and it is the lowest price
guaranteed uh there's also event
cancellation protection there's job loss
protection it's just the best way to do
it it's the best way to do it and it
also allows you to get the best deals
possible at the last minute not to
mention they've got exclusive Flash
Deals they've got sponsored deals on
tickets for football basketball baseball
concerts comic theater and more game
time has deals on tickets right up to
the start of the event and even an hour
after it starts all right this is the
best way and the best place to find
those last minute seats so here's the
here's here's what I want you to do I
want you to take the guest work out of
buying tickets with game time you're
going to download the game time app
create an account and use code taste
buds for what for $20 off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account and redeem code taste buds t a s
bu U DS for $20 off download
Gametime download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed folks it is the holiday
season for God's sakes today is
Christmas day and it is a bustling
holiday season at that all right and
when you're
bustling all right and you're being
bustled and the holidays are bustling
around you you want to remember to eat
right and you want to be able to eat
right
conveniently what am I getting at I'm
getting at factor factor America's
number one ready to eat meal delivery
service they can help you eat well for
breakfast for lunch and for dinner with
Chef prepared dietitian approved ready
to eat meals that are delivered where
straight to your door you'll save time
you'll stay on track and your healthy
lifestyle will remain intact while you
are tackling what those bustling
holidays all the holidays to do you're
running around you're buying gifts you
got to visit people you this person's
visiting you whatever it is you don't
want to have to think about how do you
get the right meal together for each
meal of the day cross meal prepping off
your list this holiday season with
Factor you're going to skip the meal
planning you're going to skip the
grocery shopping The Chopping the
prepping the cleaning up and you're just
going to get factors fresh never frozen
meals delivered straight to your door
and guess what they're ready in Just 2
minutes two minutes all you got to do is
heat it and enjoy treat yourself all
right there's 35 Plus Chef created meals
every week that support a healthy
lifestyle and meet your ve meal
preferences whether it's a calorie smart
or vegan or veggie or Protein Plus or
you know wholesome options whatever you
want and Factor again it's not just for
dinner you can count on extra
convenience any time of the day with an
assortment of 55 plus add-ons to suit
various preferences and tastes you can
choose from Quick breakfast items lunch
to go uh grab and go snacks ready to
drink cold pressed juices shakes
Smoothie smoothies factors they're
covering all the bases here people all
right and they offset 100% of delivery
emissions okay and Source 100% renewable
electricity for the production sites and
offices where they're running the show
all right I I I think it's cool that
factor is a sustainable choice not just
a convenient one so head toctor
meals.com
tastebuds and use code tastebuds 5 to
get 50% off that's code tastebuds 5 at
Factor
meals.com
tastebuds to get 50% off it's it's the
same the basic idea is always the basic
idea I beg to differ your potato your
potato salad your potato salad potatoes
but all different ingredients I know why
the twice baked potato is still all
potato ingredient I know why and it is
my biggest strike against the baked
potato I know why there's a difference
here because my biggest problem with the
potato is the baked potato is this you
put first of all you have to make it
1,000% unhealthy to even want to eat it
nobody if you're eating a regular old
baked potato which is salt baked sweet
potato all the time I love it I I will
eat a baked sweet potato too but I think
most people when they talk baked potato
they're talking the russet sure whatever
I will if you eating it with anything
more than Salt and Pepper or I'm sorry
if you're eating it with just salt and
pepper you're doing that because you're
like I don't want to eat like a bad for
me potato thing right now right most of
the time if you want to really Hammer a
bake potato you are covering that thing
and stuff that's bad for you fine
whatever I'm not saying potato Sal's
healthy for you when you do that the
same thing always happens you got some
great bites at the top of that thing and
eventually you get to the bottom bites
that are just potato and it sucks and
that's why a twice baked potato is not
the same thing cuz a twice baked potato
is is mashing the insides and then
you're just scooping it out with like a
spoon you don't get to change the baked
potato from the twice baked potato
because of the way that you choose to
approach eating it it doesn't matter now
it doesn't matter that's just experience
I don't I I I ration my stuff in a baked
potato you can't ration it it's all
dumped on top I push it to one side and
then I take a scoop in the fork and then
I take the other side and I get equal
bites throughout the whole potato just
cuz you haven't figured that out doesn't
mean
that I've never said this to you before
your mother's ass I don't believe that
for two seconds even if I I don't
believe that for two seconds I don't
believe for two seconds that you shove
the stuff to the side you think what
about if I just dial up another thing on
it what does it matter buddy you're
going go to the go to theam please thank
you go to the ER you're eating half a
tub of sour cream at this point I mean
it's so you're eating a bowl of
mayonnaise it's nuts it's nuts you're
eating a bowl of mayonnaise or oil if
you do if you do uh uh the right
proportion of mayo in my opinion if you
make the potato Sal properly with mayo
you are not getting anywhere near that
intake that you're getting if you do the
right proportion of toppings on the Big
Potato anyone can make that but the
right portion proportion of Toppings is
not going to get you through that whole
potato that's why can't you just throw a
little bit more on it you could you have
bacon bits and shreded cheese right
there you can throw more on it so you're
creating a problem where there is none
is what I'm saying no no what I'm saying
is this I'm saying that you cuz you
really hammered that idea of the
restaurant baked potato of the the way
they prep it and all that and what I'm
saying to you is every time I've have
had that in a
restaurant I I dude I sto I know the
experience I've had it I
loaded potato sidestep that experience
as a young I'd say in my teens not a
young child but in my teens I stopped
getting the loaded baked potato when my
parents would take me out to a
restaurant cuz I was like I'm tired of
it halfway through becoming just a baked
potato you don't get it like it's not
enough what about this you love the skin
right me too why couldn't you then take
a knife to it slice the potato and then
dip it on on the top and eat it I don't
have a problem with the skin I have a
problem with there being half of potato
with nothing on it but do you hear what
I'm saying no it solves your problem
right there okay you have a baked potato
it's loaded on top right you take a
knife and a fork and you cut a piece of
the potato instead of eating it like
from it's a bowl you cut it and you Spar
that in your fork you dip it on top you
put it in your mouth and as you go
you're eating it and you're getting
equal rations of the toppings I mean
look you I not just blow your ballls
off no you could but the whole point is
just scooping it out from its own
insides as you now you now you're get
what the point of it is I don't know I'm
saying like I hear you you know why you
can't do what you just said half the
time cuz it's got that tin foil around
the skin that has at this point been
almost fused into the potato itself it's
not meant to be eaten that way yeah I I
will say there is danger of eating some
tin for yeah yeah I will tell you this I
will give you a great you want to hear
my baked potato
recipe yes this is great and it only
salt and pepper uh you take a baked
potato or you take a regular potato you
cook it and put on salt and pepper well
here how that a recipe here's what you
do I didn't finish yet you're right
here's what you do poke it with holes
yeah obviously which is what I'm doing
to your
Argan take that
potato coat it in olive oil all right
however you can but coated in olive oil
then take it roll
it in coarse sea salt and then get it
with fresh ground pepper all around the
olive oil will make that stuff stick to
it then you put it in the foil I mean
olive oil salt and pepper will make and
then you bake it and then when you open
that thing up it doesn't need anything
it's ready to go yeah yeah do not do not
do not soak it in the you just brush the
oil on top and it'll stay on for soak it
in the oil no like what I'm saying is
you roll it in oil once and then rolling
away I just spray the I have an olive
oil I would imagine that's the same
issue once you start digging in there
you're not getting that that oil is only
covering your surface
bites what the hell are you talking
about what am I talking about you said a
baked potato yeah yeah okay so when the
oil just helps it get crispy on the
outside that's all that's all that's
doing okay I'm saying once you're inside
it's just raw
potato PL po any potato you got to bake
the [__] out of it you got to bake the
[__] out of it because the amount of
times it's it's it's not you want it to
be fluffy you want to be able to mash it
with a fork basically like you want it
truly fluffy and what I do is because
I'm
home I get the foil completely off of it
then I cut it in half then I do this and
then you're cutting it with a knife and
fork and you're getting salt and pepper
so you could do that with the other
thing too in a restaurant way eat in a
restaurant which is the only place I've
ever gotten a loaded baked potato
because I I got to be honest with you if
I was in someone's home and they were
making loaded big potatoes I'd be like I
got I would feel like I was in a crack
house like I have to get out of here
quite the opposite I would be like get
out of here nobody ever does that I'm
I'm excited it's it's it's it is B I
don't even I don't even think to have a
baked potato that's that's the thing
with a baked potato for me I don't think
about baked potato I don't think to make
it I don't think to have it I don't
think any it just when it comes across
my desk and I'm like whoa I'll guess
I'll eat this B is that what I used to
do no you know what I used to do at
Wendy's yeah Wendy's has baked potatoes
and because they baked potatoes they
would give you the sour cream in this
little like pack it was you going to now
say another thing solving your own
argument listen no no listen to this it
was a packet but it was a weird packet
it was cold they kept it really cold and
it was in this like triangular
thing it was great it was great it was a
great perfect amount of sour I remember
that I know the triying I would ask for
some of those sour creams with my fries
and then I would take the sour cream and
I would line the French fry with it and
oh my God and dude I remember when I
first started doing that Wendy's I
remember a couple of the drive-thru
people being like wait what I was like
like nobody's thought of
this it's great I love sour cream oh man
one thing outside the box baked potato
has some heft to it somebody you know
comes in robs the restaurant it's a
weapon you know what I'm saying like
just out of the box you know I will tell
you this you have a plateful of potato
salad you're getting chied as a sandwich
man as a sandwich man I love potato
salad potato salad in a a potato baked
potato in a sock start swinging that
around know me and oerson do together no
me and oerson sometimes have Deli days
okay where we'll go out to we'll go to
the supermarket together we'll buy rolls
we'll buy all kinds of lunch meats yeah
I've been pretty this yeah and we'll buy
potato salad we did it when we were at
the beach nobody but me and Jay really
liked it uh
but whatever uh so we'll do that and you
get the potato salad and then as you're
eating your sandwich I start scooping
bites of potato salad onto the sandwich
and now the sandwich that doesn't have
Mayo on it you're getting a bite that
suddenly does have some mayo with potato
Sal you know what else too it's not I
don't know what they put in it but that
Mayo has that Tang to it it's cuz
there's probably they sour you add sour
cream but if you add too much yeah I
agree that may on that potato salad the
Mayo based P it's Tangy and man I gotta
be honest I don't think I don't know I
don't know if I like some I can't name
one thing that's Tangy that I
enjoy what do think Tang I don't think
you things in a Tangy I don't think
potato Sal should have a Tang I think
like citrus used has a Tang yeah I don't
know about that I think that's a poorly
made potato sell rhubarb tart cherries
gooseberries cranberries that's that's
more tart is it
not tomato it's the vinegar it's the
vinegar that's doing it probably right
cheese lemon tomato I don't know man I I
don't I
don't Tang I hear the word tang and I'm
like potato salad shouldn't have Tang to
it it's a improperly made it does no I'm
saying that's a bad it's poorly made if
it does is what I'm saying all right
what is a Tangi flavor a Tangy flavor or
smell is one that's Sharp especially a
flavor like that of a lemon juice or a
the potato salad that your lady made is
how it should taste it should it should
have a balance to it okay so there's
some sour cream there's some mayo
there's salt and pepper obviously
there's some chives you loved it you
can't go like that one was good that's
I'm saying I despise the mbased potato
salad so much that it kind of just is a
blanket statement for me but you like
that one so you don't despise it the
just desp yeah but again it's what comes
across my desk right she ate that potato
salad twice in my life I'm telling you
what comes across my desk is that Deli
one that you shove into the freaking
canister and you squeeze it shut and his
Mayo on the side I'm not talking about
80 like eight pounds I'm not talking
about Deli I'm not talking about shotty
Supermarket Deli I'm not talking about
every Diamond dozen Corner Store
unforunately about if you go into a good
Deli or the deli that the quality Deli
or a supermarket that is a quality Deli
counter you are going to be able to
Great Potato Sal but I can't stand what
I often see the most the only people who
like potato salad are Mormons and white
ladies who just started menopause that's
that's funny I I don't understand the
the reference syst stuff I love cold
potatoes no we already saw all these
yeah let's let's dig
deeper uh may we have half hour the fact
that they the fact that they can call
that a Sal is a mystery dating back to
the dinosaurs choosing potatoes out as
criminal baked who loves baked potatoes
this much it's always to me the the like
boring thing you you T like I I eat
baked sweet potatoes all the time at
home I do it so I so I fill myself up
with a side dish that isn't terrible for
me I if if if I could eat whatever I
want I would never eat a baked potato
ever in my life ever
why honestly I'd rather eat drywall
covered in m this person says baked
potatoes are for the severely neglected
potato salad all damn day wow there you
go salad I'm a little mayo [__] okay
baked potatoes are like eating bricks
okay salad I'm a Mayo [__] okay TI's
turning here lunch potato salad dinner
baked potato that's actually a really
good point that we haven't
discussed yours is dinner mine is lunch
potato salad with barbecue baked potato
with steak I asked you which one I said
which do you prefer that's what I said
that's we posted which do you prefer
potato salad with barbecue baked potato
with steak does nothing for us it does
nothing an average baked potato is
better than an average potato salad but
a really good potato salad blows my
balls off got to go that's a very good
point that's a very par for the course I
think I do think a baked potato is
better than potato salad but the best
potato salad is going to be better than
the best baked potato yes baked potato
is
divine what planet do you live on it's a
it's a thing B it's like saying you know
what I love canned corn nothing is as
good as canned corn many things are as
good as the baked potato or the canned
corn this is potato salad you it's a
it's a creation give me the uh give me
the uh definition of divine let's see if
if any of it rings
true of from or like God or a god
excellent and delightful okay I I could
see a baked potato being like this
potato is excellent and delightful
that's not what they meant and you know
it they meant the God
one they meant the God one baked potato
should have been abandoned when we
discovered french fries I don't disagree
you're a disgrace if you choose potato
salad over a heartwarming baked potato
it's orphanage food for crust sakes
heartwarming talk about that that's big
Pat of butter in there man some people
don't even put the sour cream CH at home
when I was little baked potato just
meant potato with but finid food was
going to get a bigger laugh it bothers
me that it didn't but it's it's like
Oliver Twist food we didn't we didn't
even talk about the butter I that's how
I ate it was just split open with butter
in it uh
I I think butter salt and pepper it's
not it's not bad but it's never
anybody's first choice I I don't
think but I guarantee McDonald's has
never okay never had a bad baked potato
but I have had some very effed up potato
salads that's not true that and what
that's I would say that's most most
people's experience that statement is
not true I've never had a bad baked
potato you have no he said I've never
didn't he say I've never had a baked
potato he's never had a bad baked potato
but he said but okay the first part of
the sentence is not true you have had
bad baked potatoes but a bad baked
potato doesn't punch you across the jaw
right you just go eh it's a little raw
in the middle or whatever like like I
don't want anymore but a potato salad I
might I might be loble to spit it out
first bite much like that other kid's
argument of the best potato salad is
going to be better than the best baked
potato I will 100% agree the worst
potato salad is going to it's going to
be so much worse than the worst biged
potato I've had shitty experiences with
that [__] people call salad than
I've had with a baked potato potato
salad is [__] from a
butt what all right give that the win
let's retweet Ren insane at insanely in
love follow heard it that way oh wait no
that I'm sorry that was the wrong person
well you can follow that person too the
winner is Alex at angel with anore
r potato Sal that's so funny dude that's
so it's just
so potato salad is gross all Deli salads
are TR stop putting mayo and sugar in
cold food and calling it
salad salad takes more time to make
especially if you do it right your
animals this is this is why I get mad at
the at sometimes at the comments people
go well actually there someone just said
you take it too seriously a little more
pimp right there you all take things too
seriously on here sometimes there are
actual Wars happening all right in the
world and you're on Twitter yelling at
some because of unfunny oh you're that's
silly there's Wars going on since the
beginning of time every single day is
this for us can't take a break no I'm
sorry max out comments that's just
Twitter's recommended oh okay okay oh oh
okay okay so so here's my here's my
problem with a lot of the comments and
this happens a lot with any nuanced food
because I would say potato out is a
Nuance food you have to get it
right it drives me crazy when people are
judging it based on well the one store I
go to all the time that has it in the
one version sucks so therefore all of it
is ter we're all affected by that the
show is affected by you would never you
would never judge any unnuanced food
that way meaning
steak if you had bad steak at a bad
restaurant you wouldn't go to that
restaurant get steak you would find a
place that great
steak uh get baked potato is a good
example of of that uh uh chicken
whatever it is Fried Chicken you would
never go Fried Chicken sucks the place
the every time I get it it's this it's
it's no you you would go to a bad place
and then find a good place it just
drives me crazy that it's like potato
salad is always this it's like no it's
not it's not always that that's that in
fact if you get out there is the
minority of potato salad I would go as
far
as I just did the [__] I love it
right out of breath I love it I love
when you're talking right out of breath
I love it it's
uh um all right yeah let's we we can
have a trunade up okay yeah what we got
P we we we didn't we didn't BS up top so
we run right into the let's let's let's
take it to let's take it to 40 minutes I
feel bad doing less than 40 but uh how
is it now 35 we're right here so we want
to talk for five more minutes yeah we're
right here all right we can talking
about this I think um yes I think this I
think this is baked this
conversation thank you very much the uh
oh my friend uh what did my friend Brian
just could call me the guy went to Bur
Lobster with he'll call me in like like
right before I I have to leave for show
on the
road and it'll be like uh he'll be
like s what makes me laugh he'll be like
Joe look I know you're busy but uh I
just you know look I'm going to throw it
out there you use it if you want to use
it you know you're in Pittsburgh tonight
I if I were you I'd hit the stage I'd
say folks I thought it was going to be a
nice city but this place is the pits
place is going to go wild
he goes you know whatever you think you
know what you're doing then fine don't
use it but it's it really makes me laugh
but you I just you made me think of that
because you said this conversation's big
yeah yeah yeah how was did he did he
pass he passed away a few hours ago
no oh he was like 100 but we're talking
about the
Stephano uh no Norman Norman he was I
think he was about 100 oh look at that
one year shy
wow uh I met him once he was just on
television not long ago yeah I met him
once he was a great guy about 99 that's
no he he Liv 100 he said it's said
101 yeah oh I'm doing the math wrong 101
all right you did it nor he worked until
the end 101 yeah he did uh Norman Le
give him a one thing I want to give know
who he is he's he's responsible for I
believe my favorite telev show of all
time I really really need to give a
shout out to the
fans the
influx of McDonald's love that I am
seeing at shows and in my DMs is
nuts I'm getting McDonald's story after
McDonald's story getting sent to me of
like like like somebody sent me multiple
people send me the same story like right
which is very so it means people are
being very thoughtful but like
McDonald's is starting a new like down
low restaurant that they're
teasing called cosmics what are you
talking about right now McDonald's is
starting a new restaurant called cosmics
resta food place no it's like a spin
it's like an offshoot of McDonald's and
it's called cosmics give me the mission
statement here they they're keeping
everything very mysterious but they said
one thing they're going to do cosmics is
it's based on a character they
introduced in the 80 named Cosmic that
was like an alien so it's another fast
food joint yeah it's it's an offshoot of
McDonald's it's like a it's like it's
like a very it's like picture picture wo
Tang it's like another wuang under the
Wang is anyone else known to do that
I've never seen Burger King be like now
we've got burger prins or whatever like
so doing a place called cosmics and
apparently there's going to be a huge
focus on specialty drinks like flavored
like sodas and slushies and like fun
like drinks okay and apparently it's
inspired by apparently the uh smash
success of that Grimace Shake no way
yeah so so anyway which we thought
wasn't good we were like it's too much
it was it didn't tast like so but the
the fan I love all of you you guys are
and then people showing up at shows
bringing
me I've gotten multip multiple pairs of
McDonald socks I have multiple pairs at
this point guy in Pittsburgh brought me
uh the the the Joker the Heath Ledger
Joker like an action figure of it uh but
as Ronald
McDonald like wild stuff another kid at
that show brought me this artwork made
around like people are got love it got
to love it I I actually you just you
just made me realize something on dece
when's this coming out this one this no
idea tomorrow Monday let me see because
if this is love of just like people
bringing stuff out is just wild the
McDonald's gifts it's awesome and I'm
not I know I'm not mentioning everybody
guys I'm sorry but like it's so they
don't expect you to mention every gift
you ever dude I did Buffalo some kid I I
walked on stage and there was a
cheeseburger sitting on
stage from mix yeah
so you went and got it and he put it
there and you didn't you didn't touch
that I didn't eat it but no as soon as I
said hi how you doing some kid gs on I
brought you a J Parker they still do
those diced onions yeah they still do
that yeah nice touch all right let's go
to the vote going to the phones Humble
Pie here we go what do you think it's
going to do what do you think here what
do you think I I I clearly think baked
potato is going to take it uh but is
that refreshed pimp is that the most
refreshed I'm trying to see what the
number of votes here votes just under
5,000 okay yeah I think baked potato's
going to take it
I uh Here We Go drum roll
please wo we got a baked potato win here
71.6% to 28.4 for the potato salad
that's I mean you know last week we did
gifts giving and receiving we thought it
was going to be bigger and I'm surprised
that this is this big of a disparity I
don't care but I will take two W's in a
row these were two needed wins for you
too this might have really this might
put me in a bad position now we got to
check the board you might be way closer
to being tied with me now I was way
ahead yeah I'm making up some grounds
well I still love you Bab love you
too all right what's up taste buddies uh
do not I'm telling you right now don't
skip this okay um I'm here right now
with pimp hey and uh D roza is is not
here right now we we bat shoot our
episodes and um I'm not sure exactly
when this announcement will be made uh
but there might not be an episode after
it there might be um so right now I
don't know so we'll leave it at that uh
but what I am here to tell you um I'm
happy I'm sad uh but
uh uh homeless pimp is is going to be
leaving no press Network um and
obviously we love you to pieces love you
guys too I'll miss you and we had such a
blast and um you know obviously we don't
want him to go or anything but pimp you
know is is is in this industry and has a
lot of opportunity and is uh doing a lot
of big things right now and so we just
want to wish him well and send him off
and hope that his career grows and grows
and grows um you know so this is the end
of an era with pimp we will continue the
show um we're working that all out right
now we're going to be coming back uh
with a new space and uh just some some
new things and a new producer uh you
know so but pimp uh and I know we're
dropping this on you but what happened
was we bat shot the episodes and then
this decision came after that and so we
couldn't go back and give an episode for
it now what I will tell you is we did
record hey bab today and we did get to
have a full sendoff for pimp on the hey
Bap episode so it would essentially be
the same exact thing on the taste bud so
you are not not getting uh a proper
goodbye uh to pimp and a send off to
pimp if you go and watch uh this week's
or this past week's or this coming
week's uh hey babe oh this comes out
before it so we got to figure that out
oh yeah yeah yeah all right so I don't
know this is like time travel yeah I
don't know we'll figure that out but um
yeah pimp just you want to say a couple
words taste buds love all the taste
buddies love the show sad to leave but
uh you know hopefully we'll get to make
it maybe even something else I'd love a
a d Roa single camera ditch sitcom
which what we've always dreamed of
really all roads are leading to that
yeah no it's not like we will not figure
something out and work again but like
you know like I said we wish pimp the
best he's killing it right now and uh
look out for him and all of his projects
and uh we know we'll to have him fun
here and this is a chance to shake it up
a little bit and uh we're going to come
back and it'll be the same show you love
but you know we're going to try to like
I said change the space we'll have a new
producer and so wish him well we wish us
well uh sorry to tell you in the fashion
but it was better than not telling you
at all U and if by chance cuz I don't
know the math right now by chance I'm
this is coming out on a Monday and the
hey bab episode where you leave and we
announce it is in three days from now
then I apologize to every well the hey
bab people but might be a few weeks it's
it's it's a few weeks well look well we
did the Christmas it's all the same
messaging we don't understand right now
the timing of anything so this might
apply it might not apply we might put it
up right now we might put it up in a
month he might come back again and and
this is
moot but um Jesus of the podcast yeah
just just understand what I have to do
here right now right um you know I had
to like while we're doing some house
cleaning for the fans when is D roza
going to get punished for season two and
three right it's two punishments Ed well
three I think I'm losing right now or
wait has it passed have we passed 156
episode6 yeah oh yeah oh well then we
need an accounting stat on who lost the
third season uh he did lose the the the
second um and so we are working on a
punishment for that right now if you do
don't recall the first punishment was uh
during the first live ever uh live
stream of taste buds and that was a
two-hour episode and uh Joe was on that
episode 100% of it in full to the nines
Ronald McDonald a gear he was Ronald
that day or he was Donald McRonald or
whatever he was something like that yeah
um yeah so we're working on the second
one and I might have lost and we'll be
working on that third one guess
V oh s Lost season three oh really here
we go that's
interesting I think you need a schedule
for these punishments 30 so wait so wait
but that's all right yeah we
just we got to figure it out because
it's it's basically every year so it
should be 52 EPS right but we've passed
it so I shouldn't be 24 and 18 the mat
doesn't work like I said with all this
re readjusting everything maybe you
start off every year with the punishment
okay yeah look at he's still dropping
some Bon moths before he leaves um you
could see here we're just trying to give
you guys information um you know we
might be down um during the month of Jan
we're going to be recording EPS but
we're also trying to get a new space and
we're trying to you know just fig you
know figure things out so we might be
down for the month of January um if
we're not then you'll see an episode but
if we are that means we're just coming
back in fed with a revamp um and uh
we'll give you some time to miss us and
we will mourn our pimpy and uh yeah so
love you guys and thank you for all your
support thus far continued support
continued support for pimp and his
career um you know we had a blast so
it's it's it's really Bittersweet I
don't want to see him go but I'm very
very happy and proud for him and uh yeah
that's it so appreciate you guys if the
hey if the hey bab episode didn't come
out yet watch that one and that'll be a
full app of us basically pimp was our
guest in that episode um yeah I just
want to say thanks to the fans thanks to
you and D Roa love you guys appreciate
it was a fun uh fun show one of the best
pods really yeah it was it was an
absolute blast man it was an absolute
blast some of the hardest I've laughed
in my life especially in in the last
three years um yeah so uh and and and
and and if it didn't come out then you
guys that episode is coming out um so
appreciate you thank you taste
they com to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools going to fight but
only one food can be right taste buds
man yeah they coming to the